that's unlike them peace be upon you
when I'm my name is a foreigner e and
not on the deed so stay tuned and
they'll be right back
this is like I'm gonna die Salam aleikum
peace be unto you welcome to the Deen
show this week we have our little
brother
so far he's in town and he's back on a
Dean show and you know he's read over
2200 2200 books with the help of his
parents he's written to and strangers is
one of them fire and we're gonna be
talking about we're gonna be asking them
some questions it was very exciting last
time you know we had a lot of the the
young Muslims really exciting and the
non-muslims they want to know what these
Muslims are teaching their kids so tune
in stay tuned don't go nowhere we're
gonna pick his brain with the little
Muslims so far here on the Dean show sit
tight don't go nowhere
this is the things that they enjoy
so far yes you remember me yeah so I'll
lake home hey careful ah what'd I just
say what do we just say peace be upon
you peace be upon you how you been
hundun la we did a good show last time
huh yeah it was really exciting I'm glad
you're back you didn't forget about us
yeah yeah yeah so look you've written
some books and last time we talked about
these books you you read about what how
many books have you read so far um about
more than 2,000 mm now are these small
books big books what is it how many how
big are the books about like some of
them I baked some of them some are like
three pages some 10 pages 20 pages small
books but you read a lot of books yeah
that's good you like reading yeah yeah
I'm doing love so you're here and we're
gonna ask you some questions
deal yeah and then you know what I got a
surprise for you have you have you met
Abraham
have you seen Abraham on the Dean show
he's gonna come out and he's gonna ask
you some questions too you cool with
that
yeah okay all right so strangers last
time we talked about strangers let's
talk about this for a second strangers
well what's a stranger here's a person
who you don't know okay so if someone
says they open their window right and
they said come here little boy let me
give you a piece of candy what do you do
say no no wait
what if he says look I'll give you a you
know Big Mac quarter pounder with cheese
or a happy meal yeah okay good good you
don't get in the car get the Big Mac or
a happy meal no run why because that's a
stranger you got it yeah yes so that's
what you talk about in your book yeah
yeah
now I also mentioned fire now what's
this about starting a fire why would you
write a book about fire so how do
get a escape plan and how to get out of
the fire when you're in that situation
like that mm-hmm
so what do we do if there's a fire do we
run in the fire no yeah out of the fire
yeah but okay so what tell me a little
bit about it so so after the fire then
you run out and yeah um you have to go
go to the closest neighbor and tell them
to let them use yourself or their cell
phone and call 911 right right but if
you didn't maybe read your book or the
parents didn't teach the kids that
anyone know this they could get stuck in
the fire yeah right okay good so
strangers stay away from strangers and
strangers what someone you just you
don't know yeah okay and what else do
you cover in your book do you remember
anything else yeah tell me tell us to
call mine alone and run away okay so now
let me you know that Islam we know that
it's a complete way of life it's a way
of life that we live it's a way of life
of all the messengers and God sent Islam
he sent this way of life to all of us
that we submit to the one God the God of
all that exists yeah now in this way of
life all right
there are manners that we follow and
we're going to talk about some of these
manners all right because the our
brothers and humanity they're not yet
Muslims and non-muslims some might have
some misconceptions about Islam so how
does it slam what is Islam teach does it
teach you to be rude to people mean to
people who are not Muslim what is this
long teacher and some teaches us to be
nice to people and kind and tell them to
worship to break time to do what to
throw up right back to to worship the
right path what do you mean like worship
Allah
oh you mean worshipped okay to worship
God yeah
okay now we got it makes sense and you
mentioned something before you said God
is the one Allah is the one who gives in
intelligence to the people huh right so
that's the God we worship the God who
gave intelligence to all people who
created everything in this universe do
you worship the moon no you worship a
moon god no no how about do you worship
Muhammad no do you worship Jesus no who
do you worship I worship Allah the one
who created Jesus yes who created
everything yes that makes sense that
makes sense and how about your family
now are you good to your parents
yeah why because why do you listen to
him you'd like to ask a lot of wise
right why this why that I'm gonna ask
you a lot of wise so does Islam teach
you this yeah okay last time when we
were on the show you you recited the
opening chapter to the verbatim word of
God the Quran yes has truths and proves
that it's from indeed the creator of
this heaven the creator of all that
exists does God that we worship Allah
now you you recited it the al-fatiha the
opening chapter would you mind
this time would you mind reciting it and
then translating it for us giving us the
meaning in English can you do that yeah
okay go ahead
I seek refuge of Allah from the accursed
Satan the name of Allah the beneficent
the merciful all praise be to Allah lord
of the worlds
al rahman al rahim the beneficent the
merciful my leaky air would be all over
the day of judgment
yeah cannot do a Yakima stain the alone
we worship the alone we ask for help
Athena said Martin was thinking the
aloneness will help seal in the worship
throughout the new xenon until I lay him
the pathway you the person you have
favoured I do but I lay in not about the
who earned your anger what a darling nor
the particle in straight yes I mean
that's good that's I you you just
recited it and just back to back you
gave the
the the Arabic which is the original
that's the Koran what's recited and you
gave the the meaning Wow
and this is really we encourage everyone
every Muslim should know the meaning so
they're not just saying something you
know like a parrot just sayings and
repeating something you actually know
what it means this is great you mind if
we take a break yeah we're gonna take a
break
tell them peace so long leg will be
right back
what's it hard so far here on the Dean
she'll sit tight what can you put your
dream home and you've got your dream car
but you're gonna get old and things are
gonna happen to you in your life and
then what have you got at the end of the
day is an empty dream that has no real
foundation we are gonna die and we're
gonna meet our Lord and he is going to
judge us it becomes an obligation for
each single human being to find out what
the Quran is Islam is telling us to stay
away from things which are bad for your
person in bed for the society killing of
innocent human beings human life is
precious back here on the D show was
Zohar so far I did it again see I messed
up I'm sorry
thank you can you say my name yeah
what's my name
Eddie and you're on the what Nietzsche
all right ma sha Allah all right so I
remember I told you earlier that we're
gonna have a special guest and he wants
to ask you some questions
he watched you last time on the Deen
show are you ready yeah
so a can we bring out Abraham how are
you Ziggy what's your name good fly Zeki
the flash Zuzu hey guys I'm on the way
home I got some questions to ask you
okay
can tell you--uh-uh salam alayka I did
let's know okay listen any agreed I can
come on and ask you a few questions so
uh so hi alright so far
oh you're a radical yeah dear teacher IV
what is it slam teach you because you
know I guess some people think that the
kids are radical out there you don't
look so radical you look kind of like a
nice boy keep for it I wanted used to be
that nice term and respect our family so
you're gonna be nice to me
yeah you're gonna be nice to just me or
everybody I'm gonna know
hey what else do you know you know any
sewers from the Koran yeah hey can you
fix my hair's butt fell off oh yeah
thanks all right mess out out sir
commuter senators are with me yeah what
are you waiting for
yeah a young mother fish from 4-under
little [ __ ] [ __ ] a bit with ya back up
at the head what is it so hot that I'm
not just a little bit of uh spit way
then looking for nah cool but Alec you
know any yeoman I see a little cafe do
you know why it is here a little heater
I doubt Allah whom I'll I'm gonna do
that opening mr. Hooda and I had to
learn either from my Etowah and the feet
killed in the who can in the area Tina I
need so Riku soda no [ __ ] or theta
over G like if I cut the muckety-muck if
I cut them the Minerva
some rather service my mother was sick
for Carl in heaven less area but and
have a black ol enforcer those disease
occurred
Oh madam I expected that's Vicki well I
took over her tool in person I lay here
to Sasha on my channel now a cybernetic
and let my like it though all right I'll
night little eleven little been living
like of earliest age you know
who thought you'd every and better
living I don't know a man or will I
travel Avena with the catabolism what we
know but you're cooling the Dean disease
you loopy I'm a little like a feeling
you've allocated a little Omega shadowy
animation my Allen even that I pick a la
who am i year letter crawling person can
level come on well lady it at the but
slowly that's what the head I had a
little cover as a running for sure
they mine charming companion ticket
Amalia pocket cuz you know something
marketable tahina latter sabi you need
me you're nothing it's a saloon
I didn't really mean I feel like a comfy
second column the communal most elite
and I'm not gonna take my on the skin I
cannot hold a mile high it ain't a
canonical the movie a meeting at eternal
aching madam from chef at the Chevy the
madam and it took a little martini kind
no mom almost an Fela Fela trinkets
Laura as you read the Colombian Minho
and it does over muneshwara
gonna level like a phone and laughing uh
can let in no it's of Kiera I'm Angelica
de mis guru nail are you sure Allah well
let the Koala a little mock fira marsala
marsala
you know there's a lot of people that
think you know that God Allah that he's
like a man is something yeah I'm a
manager man right yeah there's a man do
you know the Syrian occur and hollow
uh-huh yes for me please love so much
Daniela dual amulet Widowmaker logo for
nerds now you know what did you say I
know what you said I know what about the
people out there do you translate see
the law the one and only the absolute
the eternal he's not the father of
knowing Mildred nor does he have
anything
children and there's nothing comparable
I'm John hmm mashallah that makes a lot
of sense God is not like you and me and
have like grandparents and kids and
stuff that doesn't make sense that God
is like you little guy like you does it
no oh I saw okay I gotta go but I'm just
gonna sing a song real quick can you
sing it with me yeah okay I'm gonna say
first then you after me okay and you
guys can do it at home too all right
howdy howdy huggy huggy I love you oh
yeah
huggy huggy huggy when you love me too
how do you huggy huggy I live all aw
huggy huggy huggy where you love me too
hey huggy I just sent a song about I
gotta go guys
peace be with you I'll see you next time
don't go woes the far what do you think
about Abraham ah ah he is funny do you
think he's funny hmm he's like that song
he was singing huggy huggy
so listen all right tell us now we're
almost out of time you know that we you
recited the Quran verbatim Word of God
unlike any other book out there
memorized by millions all over the world
tamper free trample proof not the words
of man but the words of the creator of
the heavens and earth and anybody who's
sincere who really wants to take a look
at this book and its original they'll
see that you know what this is indeed
from the creator of the heavens and
earth you recited it and you translated
the opening chapter now there's another
piece that go with this we have the
hadith the sayings of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind upon Muhammad
peace be upon him who was a messengers
like Jesus Abraham Noah and all the
other messengers do you know any of
these authentic hadith go ahead share
one with us
the first IDs I wanna show you is when
I'm in a van abasa
and out when the prodromus awesome but
that's why I'm not having a bath always
moved by faith you apply self-restraint
and gentleness the second indeed I want
and you can find this in the book of
Mosul the second I didn't want to share
with you is wonder habla de I said when
he's one of oh honey they said he said
the power mom he said the person mom is
a little our little upset we don't fight
can never coexist in the human hearts
the last teacher will want to show to
you is on the authority of AB dilemma no
man
when the problem when he stood apart
from Mohammed a little long I left I
said God accepts the repentance of a man
right to his last gasp before he died so
was this hadith that Allah is this a law
that we worship is here a merciful God a
loving God yes so this hadith shows it
that Allah will accept the repentance of
a human being until their last dying
breath so I better hurry up and repent
for all the bad things people do right
right yeah okay well you know what we're
out of time I'd like to thank you for
stopping by again in sha Allah we can
have you back God willing okay so we
talked about self-restraint and what
else was that gentleness
so islam teaches you to be gentle yes
this is very very important is it just
with muslims or non-muslims - with
everybody how are you supposed to act
with people who who you know what they
didn't accept that you know what that
god is one that you should worship Him
alone not the worship of monkey or a man
or an elephant or you know a clown
whatever the case and they want to
worship you know a man or a saint are
you supposed to not be gentle with these
people
no you're supposed to be gentle you
can't force everybody can you put a
sword next to someone's neck and say
accept Islam no that's is that what
islam teaches you know the islam teach
you to be extreme like
extremely mean or a terrorist does Islam
teach you to do that no are you sure I'm
sure okay good good good all right well
that's all the fun we can have for today
and did you enjoy that you can remember
that people were singing that song at
home huggy huggy huggy so make sure when
you go home you hug your mommy and your
daddy and your sister and be good and do
good all right all right peace be with
you
Salaam alaikum and that was our little
brother the little Muslim in a Muslim is
one who consciously submits to the
creator of all that exists and Islam is
the system the complete way of life from
A to Z when you wake up in the morning
to when you go to bed how you conduct
yourself how you conduct yourself with
your parents how you conduct yourself
with your neighbors how you conduct
yourself with your co-worker would you
spout everything is there no guesswork
and Islam is teaching us to be gentle
and kind is Lama is teaching us to have
a relationship to have the utmost love
for our Creator the Creator who gave us
this air that we breathe who's feeding
the fish in the sea who's feeding the
bird in the air who took care of you
when you and your mother's whom and
who's feeding you and giving you the air
that you breathe right now establish a
direct dial up a direct connection with
the create of all that exists the
Creator of Jesus Moses Abraham the
creator of the Sun and the moon worship
that one creator alone you need to put
up intermediary between you and him you
direct dial up ask him for the guidance
ask him for everything and all your
needs that's the one God that we worship
that's the foundation of Islam and if
you can understand that the rest will be
simple and we cover some of these things
being gentle and kind respectful to your
parents all these things Islam is not
calling you to kill innocent people to
strap a bomb on yourself and blow up a
building with kids in it that's not what
Islam is about and we're so thankful
that you came to the Deen show to learn
about Islam not to Fox News or CNN or
peter jing jing jing' or whoever else is
out there come to the Muslim sit with
the Muslims invite them to lunch or have
them invite you to their house go check
out the mosque your neighborhood mosque
check it out make sure that you know
what let me see if there's some some
bombs in here
make if every go check it out ask the
questions ask them to tough questions
that's how we're gonna develop an
understanding and you got to see one of
our little Muslims you got to see what
these kids are being taught and they're
being taught things that are good
because Islam encourages good good - all
good breeze Goods and this is Islam and
we'll see you next time here on the Dean
show until then peace be unto you